my question isn't with Leon I think Leon
we're going to get the best version of
him which can be tough for Kamara to
beat I think he has confidence in
himself I think he knows he can win even
he's not feeling 100 which in the last
fight he said he wasn't I think mentally
he knows that even if he's not firing
all cylinders he can still have the
talent to pull it out and beat a guy in
Kamar Usman who's regardless the
greatest wealth win of all time so for
Kamara Usman my question's not with Leon
I think we're going to get a very very
tough version of Leon Edwards from Usman
my questions going in this fight for
Kamara Usman is remember he's coming off
an injury he's coming off a long layoff
and his knees are so bad his knees are
so bad he can't really do condition
cardio he's not been able to navigate
that at some point though it's going to
catch up with him it has to right
through the city like British
[Music]
don't get involved
now Brandon
what is up fam it is March 13th it's
b-day week Casey's b day too man coming
up couple Pisces Bros and Mr Theo Vons a
lot of Pisces going down it's March 13th
it is we're in daylight what is it
called daylight savings
so we're springing forward
it always messes you up really it messes
up the kids more than anything it's the
grown adults like what's an hour what's
an hour man whatever uh fresh off the
boat from Oklahoma City shout out to OKC
and the uh Bricktown comedy club uh come
up next for me is Tacoma that is next
Thursday Friday Saturday Tacoma
Washington right outside Seattle I'm in
Atlanta Spokane uh La Jolla and then the
Europe tour the pre-sale is over so now
just go get your regular tickets Belfast
June 15th Glasgow June 17th Manchester
June 18th London June 22nd Cardiff June
23rd Dublin June 25th get you some let's
get right on into it man you have UFC
286 coming up this truck and Saturday
nice little time too for the parents uh
it could be good or bad because usually
you can put the kids to bed and then
just enjoy the fights in silence or you
can just have them run around and you
can't pay attention to the fights
because this is that 2 p.m Pacific time
which is prime time for London so I'd
rather be prime time for London
especially when you have a car to this
magnitude it's the O2 Arena in London
out there uh and it is a banger
now it is missing a few key people when
you think of a London card you're
missing uh Patty pimlet he's having
surgery uh meatball's not on there uh
Tom aspinall who I think is uh besides
Patty the biggest kind of
um I I don't know if you call him a
prospect at this point he's right so
high but he's he's the one kind of
London uh Europe Mainstay that's not on
the card due to injury two coming off
that leg injury against uh Curtis blades
so they're missing a little bit of star
power on this thing but it's still
pretty loaded and you have some
up-and-comers who are filthy uh I'll
actually start breaking down this card
with uh the one to watch would be on the
early prelims on ESPN Plus or UFC Fight
Pass and this this Christian Leroy
Duncan if you haven't seen this
gentleman fight he is Mr highlight I
know Justin gaichi who's also the
comitive on this is nicknames the
Highlight this Christian uh Duncan is a
highlight to say the least if you've
never heard of this kid go look up his
fights right now he's throwing Spinning
Wheel kicks he'll kick your freaking
face off he's 7-0 he is uh has Superstar
written all over him he is a complete
Savage look winning look at his record
so that 6-0 right
so this is cage Wars and cage Wars I
don't know if you've heard of cage
Warriors for your American fans but a
few guys have come out of there I'll
just take a stab at it uh you have um oh
I don't know Conor McGregor Michael Biz
being Tom aspinall
um Patty pimlet as the most recent big
name come out of there this gentleman
comes out of there and this Christian
Duncan is a Savage so this is some of
his wins in cage Wars uh spinning elbow
in round one flying knees around 3 40
seconds
um so he does some fun stuff so he has
three so fly knees spinning elbow
spinning elbow uh Knockouts he's a fun
one to watch so I'd be on the prelims
one to kind of you know make some money
on it that wouldn't be a bad uh deal
there Joy uh yeah Joanne Woods fighting
Jay Herbert's fighting so you got some
guys man Malcolm uh Gordon they always
toss him to the just the next Savage
coming up against Jake Hadley Jake
Hadley is a monster as well these are
those young kind of up and coming not so
much with Jay Herbert and he's training
partners with Leon Edwards but for the
rest of them they're the new crop coming
out of uh that side of the pond so the
the USC was smart about this you also
got a good prelim fight
um that kicks off the main prelim card
and Muhammad uh Muhammad Mohammed MO
this is a kid who's he's undefeated his
last fight he you know it was going a
little tough for him uh he's the
absolute nightmare to deal with Malcolm
Gorn shout out to Malcolm Gorn taking on
all these up and coming Savages but
Malcolm Gordon game while he could
handle he ended up pulling the fight out
in the third round uh with I mean didn't
have much time to go in the third round
either he was losing that fight
um you know he wanted submission armbar
he talked about he wants to fight for a
title especially that division hey man
we got to pump the brakes a little bit
it's a marathon not a Sprint
um so you gotta just pull the brakes
just a tad because he has a lot of work
to do he has Superstar and Champion
written all over him but God just slow
down dude Slow Down slow down but he's
gonna be a champ one of these days at
flyweight but he's just not there to
compete with those top five guys but he
thinks he is but he needs to have his
team around and let him know like let's
let's take it slower you know you're not
getting your title shot beating uh
Rafael fijo you know what I'm saying so
just chill but he has all the mark
makings of a world champion and then one
of my favorites
um my absolute favorites Jack Shore is
fighting and it uh he decided to go up
in uh the weight class he's at
featherweight now I think his exactly
where he belongs he's been killing
himself uh uh trying to make that weight
so now he's can kind of not crush his
body and fight at featherweight I think
he's gonna do the damn thing so shout
out to our boy Jack Shore uh he's my
locked pick of the [__]
card I think Jack short gets it done now
when you get to the main card you got
Marvin Victoria this is this main card's
fun you got Marvin Victoria Roman uh
Victoria you know he he's coming off a
loss to Robert Whittaker that might be
the best version of Robert Whittaker
we've ever seen
um you know but nothing to hang your
head on that
um you know before that I beat Paulo
Costa he had to fight with Izzy before
that he was on a [__] straight up
tear you know Kevin Holland Jack
Hermanson uh Carl Robertson so the kid
has it all we you know we love uh Marvin
Victoria around here if you haven't seen
the food truck he's on there one of my
favorite guys to be on there just a good
dude he's just a sponge constantly
getting better it's a great fight for my
inventory
um I'm taking Victorian this one Jeff
from Maya Casey O'Neill
good fight you know uh wood I think you
could put uh Joanne wood on there too if
you wanted to have a female fight on
there but they decided to go with
Jennifer Maya and Casey O'Neill for that
reason uh welterweight Gunner Nelson who
is always a staple on the London cards
uh this is a battle it's really a clash
of styles it's it should be uh I'm sure
Gunner's favorite in this gen Gunner
Nelson Brian barbarina you have a
straight up grapple over straight up
brawler
um thousands minus 425 for God's sakes
you know so
um this is just can Gunner Nelson not
get clip coming in because Brian
barbarina throws them Barbarian bombs so
uh you hope Gunner Nelson gets back on
track he's the guy who he goes on a
streak if you go go on his record chin
he's the guy who goes on the street and
loses the big one to get him to that
next level
um it's been an up and down kind of
career for me start off 13-0 and they
lost to Rick's story uh beat Brandon
thatch lost Damian Maya
um they'd be some good guys lost to
pontoonibio then beat uh the Brazilian
Alex Oliveira the cowboy there he lost
to Leon Edwards via Split Decision
the kid's [__] talented man they lost
to Gilbert Burns decision so he's losing
a top spare guys you know but he's never
had that breakout fight he just hasn't
um he's up and down so he's two and two
I was last four you know that's kind of
him in a nutshell I don't think he ever
be a champ uh but he has the
capabilities to be anybody on any given
night he just hasn't got over that hump
yet but he's one of my faves man but for
Brian Barry and his caution to win
you're going to get taken down you got
to clip before it gets taken down you
know and for Brian barbarina you know
they gave him the freaking Legends tour
there with Matt Brown Robbie Lawler and
dos anjos ended up you know losing dos
anjos dosan just kind of gave it to him
but before that this dude has four or
five of the knights so either way makes
it fun the only chance barbarina has in
this fight is landing something as
Governor Nelson's going in for a
takedown
um there's a reason why gun Nelson's
such a heavy favorite and then Comey
main event take all my money
just in the Highlight gaichi which I
think the highlights Christian Duncan
but just in the Highlight gaichi for a
variety of reasons is your highlight uh
you know he's a Denver kid
Russian credentials University of
Northern Colorado was All-American that
does not matter he doesn't use his
wrestling he refuses to use his
wrestling you would think out of any
fight
um he would use as wrestling against
Michael Chandler when they're just
brawling
um you know he lost Charles Oliveira uh
beat Michael Chandler obviously lost
khabib
um Tony Ferguson fight I think changed
the DNA of Tony Ferguson uh before that
I beat Donald Cerrone Ethan Barboza
James Vick Los deporres
so you would say if you look at Justin
gaichi's Record grow up for me chin
his best win is probably Michael
Chandler
that was fight of the year he's had some
great fun of the years uh you know that
Tony Ferguson fight tough to watch uh
sorority older Cerrone
um that's in Barboza you know had some
miles on him James fake that was a
brutal knockout they lost a dozen poor
he lost Eddie Alvarez so his best win is
you know it's storied over career as he
has and exciting as he is his most
exciting fight is Michael Chandler which
was a phenomenal [__] fight let's
take a little break from chat about fist
to cuffs uh Tacoma Washington see you
this I'm sorry next Thursday Friday
Saturday Tacoma Washington March 23rd
through 25th takes that thickboy.com get
you some this episode of the shop show
is brought to you by my friends at
betterhelp Getting to Know Yourself can
be a lifelong process I still don't know
who I am especially because we're always
growing and changing you just you grow
up you're into different things maybe
you have kids different relationships
you're constantly changing nobody stays
the same if you stay the same you're
dying you don't want that therapy is all
about deepening your self-awareness and
understanding because sometimes times we
don't know what we want or why we react
the way we do to certain things until we
talk through it you see there's a lot of
trauma in your past that helps you make
these crazy decisions my friends have
better help connect you with a licensed
therapist who can take you on that
journey of self-discovery from wherever
you are they got you covered man if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge all
right discover your potential with
better help visit betterhelp.com
schab today to get 10 off your first
month betterhelp.com shop better
help.com
schab better help
last ad read then we'll get back to the
episode listen if you guys watch any
show I do I only recommend products I
actually use and this is one I
personally use quite a bit to be honest
any Show You See Me Do whether it's
podcasts stand up whatever it is
standing around La I'm on that happy
hippo Kratom this stuff helps me tackle
my busy schedule it helps me get stuff
done sometimes it's overwhelming but
when I'm lasered focused in I'm not
thinking about I'm just getting the job
done and I feel good about it all right
it's not just some sort of energy drink
though that you take just to get instant
energy it gives you this nice balance
good mood feeling so you're not as
chippy all the time I love Kratom but
you can't just trust anybody trust my
friends at happy hippo I use this bad
boy this the sour apple uh highly
concentrated Kratom shot I use this or
they're butterscotch they have pill form
gummies powders and these uh shots are
my favorite the happy hippo that cute
little Pink Hippo on there so if you
want Kratom could actually trust it's
the best in the business it's my
Limitless formula go do my Hidden Gem of
all kratoms that's Happy hippo.com promo
code is thick three C's
t-h-i-c-c-c 23 for 20 soft for life you
can use that code as many times you want
share it with your friends family
whoever get the best Kratom on the plant
Earth we're talking about happy hippo
happyhippo.com promo code stick23 now
let's get back to the program
you know this is a fight where physiv is
better in every aspect when it comes to
striking he don't have as much power as
Justin gaichi
um you know we know Justin gate she has
a granite chin as well we've he's proven
it
um
this is more you know when you when you
break down gaichi and physiv physiv's
more technical
um this fight's gonna be on its feet
because get you refuses to wrestle
here's the thing you know gaichi and
Usman are training Partners they trained
with Trevor Whitman in high altitude in
Colorado
now if you look at their both their
matchups you would assume they're going
to camp and they're going to use a lot
of wrestling especially Usman right a
ton of wrestling
but if for whatever reason if gaichu was
like you know what I'm gonna listen to
what some of the experts are saying I'm
not saying to me I'm not an expert but
for some of those experts out there
saying man out no he doesn't wrestle
more he can wrestle should have shot a
blast double against Michael Chandler
when they're brawling certain times
should be using his wrestling
um physics not exactly a walk in the
park to take down no matter what your
wrestling credentials are things take
down defense to some over 90 percent so
you have your work cut out for you there
and that's if the game plan that Trevor
Whitman put together is to take physiv
down which it's not going to be easy and
that's not his Mo I don't think we see
that I think we see a straight up Muay
Thai match well Muay Thai match versus a
a guy who hits like a [__] Mack truck
so gaichi's always been a guy who will
eat three of yours Land one of his it's
no different here the problem is physiva
is a straight up [__] technician with
great footwork great cardio
I think for gaichi
and physiv they should both be thankful
that it's not five rounds I wish it was
five rounds this fight has the potential
if it were five rounds to change the DNA
of Justin gaichi's career and his life
for the rest of his life I think this
could be one of those fights how Justin
Gates you did Tony Ferguson where
they're just too tough for their own
good when you're facing a guy who's more
technical quicker he's just younger he
doesn't have as many miles on him as uh
his opponent they [__] you up and they
change your Dynamics your career for the
rest of your life if it was five rounds
I think just engage you could be in some
trouble three rounds I think he has the
the toughness to get through it uh
wouldn't be surprised if gaichi won
never surprised if gaichi wins it's just
a very tough technical fight for him
you're talking about a guy in physive
who's more technical quicker not as uh
many fight miles even though they're
similar in age gaichi's wrestling and
the way his fighting style you know it
catches up with you fast so by all
accounts this is not not a great fight
for Justin gaichi exciting fight Battle
of the nose jobs let's see whose nose
gonna hold up I would assume both their
noses get broken in this fight perceives
a minus 225 for a reason style wise it's
a very tough fight for Justin gaichi but
it's [__] Justin gaichi so even
though Justin I think he's gonna come
out and be down on the scorecards uh in
the first second round because the
movement and Technical style physiv and
the third round that's where
um you know Justin geji wants to drag
you into those deep rounds and get you
uh you know shooting from the hip
because he'll play that game with you in
a phone booth problem is that game
you're playing with a guy who's hits
really hard in physive also has great
hooks also is more versed in Muay Thai
also uses knees and elbows so it could
get dicey for just engage he's too tough
for his own good this is not a great
matchup for Justin gaichi but again
wouldn't be surprised if Justin gaichi
just sticks around like the goddamn
Northern Colorado Terminator into that
third round and land some huge [__]
hook and rocks uh FaZe even finishes him
off wouldn't bet on it wouldn't put my
money on it but I could definitely see
that happening
in the main event held the main event
finally it's here Leon Edwards Camaro
Usman
oh this is the third time they fought
right if you look at their fights you
look at the span of how many rounds
those guys have shared the Octagon Kamal
Usman has won the majority of those
fights and the last one where Usman gets
knocked out with literally 50 seconds
left in the fifth round uzman you I
would give Edwards the first round and
they're not clearly you'd give uh
Edwards the fifth round
um but other than that rounds two three
and four Usman is kind of beating the
breaks off him was a very competitive
fight uh Edwards said it was Matt he
just didn't feel like being in there
didn't have the energy for whatever
reason you're still able to pull it off
with that insane KO head kick uh you
know it's not a lucky thing when you
throw that that kind of jab to the high
kick so many times in training and he
did it in uh the warm-up room before
they went out that's not locked that's
not a lucky thing I think there's more
of Kumar who's been taking his eye off
the prize and just getting caught with
the perfect [__] technique from Leon
Edwards who's thrown that technique 10
000 times he's a black belt he's a
master in that technique and it paid off
um so I don't believe in luck with these
things luck could be throwing a huge
right hand and catching the guy you know
even then it's dicey because guys still
right hands but uh for Leon Edwards I
would assume this gives him some sort of
confidence laying in that kick and
knowing that that kick is there when he
needs it
um so for Kumar Usman I do have a
question about Camaro's been going in
this fight you know he he's definitely
overall the better mixed martial artists
than Leon Edwards uh they're one and one
right and one is a devastating head kick
knockout become the world champion which
is insane Leon Edwards has more hype
around him now he's finally a fan
favorite
I wouldn't say his profile has gone up
since became world champion we don't
really hear from him you don't see him
anywhere you want Rogan you know but you
don't see him all over the media doing
all the stuff I don't know if he's on
social media really it's not really his
thing I kind of enjoy that I like the
guys that just do work and don't talk to
talk
um but that being said again I still
tomorrow's still a bigger star overall
especially in the UFC eyes but again my
question isn't with Leon I think Leon
we're gonna get the best version of him
which can be tough for tomorrow to beat
I think he has confidence in himself I
think he knows he can win even he's not
feeling 100 which in the last fight he
said he wasn't I think mentally he knows
that even if he's not firing all
cylinders he can still have the talent
to pull it out and beat a guy in Kumar
Usman who's regardless the greatest
wealthy weight of all time so for Kamara
Usman my question is not with Leon I
think we're going to get a very very
tough version of Leon Edwards Usman my
questions going into this fight for
Kamara Usman is remember he's coming off
a an injury he's coming off a long
layoff
and his knees are so bad his knees are
so bad he can't really do condition
cardio he's not been able to navigate
that at some point though it's going to
catch up with him it has to so I'm just
curious how many more fights
Usman has left
I would say
one or two Max I wouldn't be surprised
if he retires after this fight
so
um
I think it might it's tough to pick
kamaro Usman it's tough to pick against
him I should say in this fight because
as many rounds as these gentlemen have
shared Camara usman's won the majority
of those rounds that being said you know
last time they fought Kamara was sailing
into a decision Victory and they got
ko'd uh kicked in the head can Leon do
that again
yes later in the rounds probably not I
think tomorrow's learned his lesson
there but early on in the confidently on
uh is gonna be a little more aggressive
what version of Kumar are we gonna get
he's coming off an injury he's coming
off a layoff
um
there's just some questions not on
Leon's side more on Camaro's side and I
think tomorrow either way win or lose
could retire after this fight so I don't
think he has much left in the tank how
many miles have put on throughout the
years of wrestling his knees you know
he's one of the greatest ever do it I
don't know how much he has left to prove
either except for just his own you know
pride and ego he needs this win and then
he can run off to the sunset right it's
over because this is the the deciding
factor the third one we don't need a
fourth one no matter what happens
um so I'm just curious with Camaro and
you never want to you know question a
guy of his stature and especially the
greatest wealth rate of all time but
what's that body do son how does that
body look like after this layoff and
you're fighting a leon Edwards a lot
more confidence and he's coming off with
KO so I don't think this fights as
favored for tomorrow as people think I
do things to be a tough night in the
office I do think they're going to learn
from that first fight
but what can you really take away from
it you're dominating the fight for the
majority of the rounds you know
definitely three out of four then he got
caught you know he got caught wasn't
lucky he was pure skill technique by
Leon Edwards but he has the capability
to knock you out in the fifth round so I
don't know if for Leon it just is that
version showing up Saturday night I
should say Saturday afternoon for uh the
American folks
draftking think so but they don't know
do they nobody knows
it's supposed to be interesting to see
what version of Kamara we get but
there's this turning of the tie too you
know Camaro has he's long in the tooth
just engages long in the tooth the
zeeves on the come up Leon Edwards has
already champ but you know it it could
be a really tough night uh in the office
for Trevor Whitman being the head coach
of Kamara Usman and Justin gaichi so
we'll see man we'll see I'm excited but
I definitely have some questions go in
this fight what version of Camaro is
coming into the Octagon in London at 2PM
Pacific time for the Americans and then
also
not only what version but how much
longer can he do it when we find out you
know his his knees are bad he's not
doing any press
he's doing zero press he's not doing any
interviews leading up this fight the
last time I saw someone do that her name
was Ronda Rousey and it means
something's going on now for tomorrow
who's this massive star he's in Black
Panther too did they still put him in
there after he lost yeah they did thank
God good for you so
um it could just be a focused thing
because when you're that big and famous
people are pulling all these directions
and he just wants to get down to
business but it does worry me because
tomorrow is a guy who's not shy of any
camera or Mike when I hear them Go Radio
silence they want to focus on the fights
maybe I'm just sensitive to it because
of Ronda Rousey but she was the last one
to do that I don't like that you know
especially for a guy who you know enjoys
the spotlight enjoys talking about the
fights builds up the fights you're
responsible to sell this card and to
shut it all down a little bit of a red
flag for me could be completely off
maybe he's focused in he's just gonna
absolutely [__] Molly [__] Leon
Edwards who knows I don't my question
with putting money on this fight is I
don't know what version of Kamal is
showing up I know we're getting the best
Leon Edwards we've ever seen I will
guarantee that with his confidence
finally he's getting his recognition and
as a fan of Leon Edwards you got to
appreciate this he's one of those guys
that just never does recognition he's
kind of the the Darius you know of the
welterweight where you're just like
who's he got a beat man the Bilal
Muhammad's finally fans like all right I
don't even like this guy but Jesus
Christ man let's give him a goddamn
title here let's give him a title shot
so for Leon he's finally getting his due
and I don't think he's gonna you know
squander that and I think he has
confidence I think his skill set's there
he's been in there how many [__]
rounds with Kamara Usman the question
lies with Camara Usman what version are
we gonna get
and I don't think he has many left
either one to two Max wouldn't be
surprised three times enough this fight
I have huge question mark Usman that's
why I would probably lean towards Leon
Edwards win this fight
which I think is completely against the
oddsmakers the other experts out there
again not referring myself as an expert
the other MMA analysts out there or MMA
entertainers out there I'm not sure how
many picked in Leon Edwards but Leon
Edwards in his backyard
but yeah if you're in bed on Leon which
I kind of leaning towards you're you're
been against the greatest ever do it his
pride his legacy is on the line that's
asking a lot for leonos to beat Kumar
Usman and especially if Camaro knows
something we don't know where he's this
is the last one he didn't get one hell
of a version of karma looseman but man
tough test tough tough test so I'm
excited for this card man but it could
be a long night in the office for Trevor
Whitman being the head coach tomorrow
who's been just engage you love Trevor
it's just a match-up thing that's all it
is just in case she has a very tough
matchup with a fizzy very very tough but
that fight is First Team all fireworks
excited for the card man let's take a
little break this episode of the shop
show is brought to you by on it I've
been with on it for a hot second listen
I'm a busy guy that's my design I like
to have a lot of my plate and on it
helps me maintain focus in order to
function and stay in the zone with all
the chaos going on with my life my
favorite is Alpha Brain Alpha Brain
Black I take the Black Label which
promotes a lot of focus and energy our
brain helps to support cognitive
functions include memory which I need
all the help I can mental speed Focus I
need it I'm always doing podcasts or
stand up and trust me mental speed I
could use a turbo and that's why I
depend on Alpha Brain Black Label it's
the intense Alpha Brain everything I do
is intense all right what are the
benefits of Alpha Brain Black us how
about AIDS and mental processing
caffeine free helps with the flow State
promotes Focus supports your memory
thank God all right and it can help you
remember names places addresses do you
know addresses or names or phone numbers
I don't focus on complex tasks think
more clearly under stressful situations
react more quickly cat-like reflexes
react like Jake Paul run away from
freaking Floyd Mayweather also has
fitness equipment like their kettlebells
seal Club Macy's sandbags yoga mats you
need better nutrition say less Anna has
MCT oil protein Warrior bars they got it
all they also offer on-demand workouts
it's the One-Stop shop to get your thick
ass in shape and get your mind working
like Jeff Bezos all right so go to
audit.com and get 10 off everything
Alpha Brain Black Alpha Brain regular
Alpha Brain instant Alpha Brain Focus
shots protein powder Warrior bars
on-demand Fitness 10 off everything I
just told you about go to audit.com Temp
set off the entire site you're welcome
let's get back to the program there's
actually memes out there too with uh
Trevor Whitman and his Fighters not
doing well if you see his face just
smiling the entire time only smiles it's
just super funny yeah yeah he's just
smiling yeah constantly non-stop quick
question for you though uh so you've huh
what so
you've been you knocked out a bunch of
people but you also have been knocked
out right so I'm sure the confidence
that comes with knocking out someone is
huge huge massive but then what happens
to your brain after you get knocked out
by a certain person it's never been
knocked out yeah so from your standpoint
or Grappler
Grappler but I I would be willing to bet
now because Kamara who's been especially
I can't make this thing more clear
Trevor Whitman is strictly a boxing
coach
strictly a boxing Savant he's one of the
probably the best ever do it him or Mark
everyone comes to boxing but Trevor
Whitman only specializes in boxing and
if kamaru Smith spend all that time up
there they're focusing on just striking
if you're fighting Leon Edwards I don't
give a [__] if Mike Tyson Bruce Lee and
Trevor Whitman Corner you're not going
to out strike Leon Edwards the only way
a path to Victory Is by grappling here's
the other thing too is Kamara Usman not
the best Jujitsu practitioner in the
world greatest wealthy of all time
probably a blue belt down there I would
say Leon Edwards has better Jujitsu when
it comes to straight up Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu so for kawara Usman you know you
got to be careful because you're when
your head coach has fallen in love with
your striking his striking you remember
now he's knocking dudes out knocked out
Gilbert Burns he's done his thing right
you got to be careful because with Leon
Edwards it doesn't matter there's not
enough hours in the day to make up that
gap between you and Leon everyone comes
to striking so you know again it's not
got a module at all his knockout of
Gilbert Burns right
um you know he's doing work there but
majority of his wins are by decision
from his grappling so you got to be
careful because you got Trevor Whitman
over here
solely specializes on boxing and if
you're spend all the time with him
you know I'm curious what the game plan
is because this fight's not gonna be one
off your boxing and if you just got
knocked out not barely knocked out not
grazed and pounded out Flatline killed
from a [__] head kick I don't give a
[__] if you're the greatest of all-time
commercial you're gonna be a little
gunshot you have to be some it has to be
this inner struggle for tomorrow because
he knows he knows I gotta get this
[__] guy down that being said I you
know we're all expecting if you are Leon
Edwards fan and I'm sure in London
England You're Expecting I know where to
knock him out via a kick or punch don't
be surprised if Leonard's got it done
via submission either
because when it comes to grappling land
or it's a better Grappler Jiu Jitsu
straight Jiu Jitsu submissions being
dangerous not his ground and pound not
his positioning I'm just strained a
straight up Brazilian Jitsu lyanna to
beat him if it was Jujitsu not a
wrestling match not a grappling match
and straight up Brazilian Jitsu and
their level of skill at submitting and
finishing opponent Leon Edwards is also
a bigger threat on the ground
so yeah it's a tough test for tomorrow
but there has to be something tomorrow
you know like you said when you get
knocked out but your coach your main guy
who's in here all the time wants you to
strike once you show off all the hard
work I get it
but this guy's better at striking across
the [__] board at everything than you
so you're saying the first time you got
knocked out turn into Grappler yes
because I could because my team won to
Grapple more but remember I came up with
Trevor Whitman
I always I always I always and this is a
knock on travel terms the one the bet
probably the best to ever do it in Mark
Henry but you know when your team's
heavy this but you're this it it's this
inner struggle so for me I always
gravitate towards Juju I loved wrestling
more I love grappling more but my head
coach was Trevor Whitman so the all the
game plans were heavy boxing I don't
[__] box these guys man these are not
in the office for Maze to Grapple so
layer my career once and again has
nothing to do with Trevor but once I get
away from Trevor and even though I had a
head coach in Tony Jeffries who was
boxing I had uh you know
um the Gracies Hannah Gracie was in my
corner all the time and I could know
that all right yeah I can box but Tony
like whatever it takes dude I don't give
a [__] yeah we have a game plan to box
this guy's ears off you see an
opportunity to take him down take him
down submit them
so I I always want to do more grappling
but because of my
you know just the proximity of where
Trevor's gym was to mine I had to kind
of gravitate more towards striking early
in my career which I regret you know but
you did enjoy striking all right like uh
because you did knock out a bunch of
people yeah yeah yeah I knocked out a
bunch of people but then I also took Pro
Club down a bunch but he's very tough to
submit it's so much stuff yeah mixing up
the game so mixing it up so if Kamal his
striking will open up more the more he
takes Leon Edwards down but his number
one emphasis going in should be called
wrestling go back to those days but it's
tough because you have the inner
struggle your head coach is the game
plan your jab your right hand doing all
that [__] yeah I just can't being
knocked out I think if I got knocked out
the next day if I had to fight someone
I'd be like [__] yeah I'd be freaking
out yeah and again it was it was a
knockout where he was knocked out with
his eyes wide open yeah and knocked out
cold cold like bad yeah
yeah but he's one of the greatest of all
time you know for a reason so you don't
want to adopt that guy and he'll figure
it out and he's dealt with it before so
that's not as far as a knockout but
dealt with that struggle of all right my
head coach really wants to focus on
striking but we're fighting you know an
elite Striker so if I say about coming
in a [__] singlet
wow
uh banaway division had some I mean
not bad drama but they have some drama
because you got uh
well it's really desert chili machine
yeah marab the machine the machine not
to be confused with birdie Boy Chrysler
the machine this is a very different
machine one is the machine because you
can drink and party one's a machine
because he will take you down like Noah
no you set the record to beat Kane
Velasquez for most takedowns in a single
fight against Peter Yan which is insane
because Peter Young's takedown defense
is [__] stupid but this shows you how
good uh Jose olives take down the fences
um that being said so for murab the
machine
the drama comes from his main training
partner and you know close friend is uh
aljo Al Jermaine Sterling Who's the
champion
so and they refused to fight each other
so there's this thing now where in that
camp in the longo uh camp matsara Camp
you know they're saying if aljo were to
beat Henry suhudo huge either
retire early or vacate and go up a
weight class
you know uh it's tough because
you know when me and Shane Carwin I
think I was right like 10 at the time
and uh you know if Shane were to beat
Brock Lesnar you know it gets it gets a
where you're at least there's a lane
where you can see you become world
champion like if I beat no Guerra I was
gonna get Brock Lesnar I beat Brock I
get a Time shot if Shane would have beat
Brock won one more we're literally on a
direct path like that I mean Shane would
talk about Shane goes you know when you
fight for a towel you get the title
that's life-changing money your kids are
set up for Life man there's there's
nobody in this world I wouldn't punch in
the face to save my kid's life or you
know to make sure that kid's comfortable
uh money-wise whether it's you my mom my
dad it doesn't matter I'm fighting him
to set my kid up I'm more online with
Shane on that I was like yeah you're
right man if we have to fight we have to
fight we've been a nightmare of a fight
for me but for marab it's like
I'm sure I'll join you close friends
train together but the end of the day
it's like you're here to be world
champion and if you're a kid if they're
like hey so you have the opportunity to
be world champion but you meet this guy
you're training with and he's gonna be
champion and the only way to be
Champions by being hit me like I don't
give a [__] but now the lines get
blurred I don't care how close you guys
are brothers blah blah blah you're not
you're not at the end of the day it's
you gotta take care of your family and
your legacy and then today the the UFC
Dana White trust me they didn't even
said this like it's a huge mistake from
Rob who's if he says he's not willing to
fight Al Joe is a huge mistake the chant
you got to understand from Rob someone
needs to sit him down the chances of you
just fighting for World title are slim
to [__] none less than one percent of
all Elite Fighters then your chance of
being Champion are probably 0.01 you
have this opportunity now they haven't
offered him anything yet and I'll just
get through [__] sahuto which is you
know a big ask
so but if that opportunity comes there
[__] all that buddy buddy stuff you have
got to fight that dude and there's a
narrative there's story there he's gonna
sell tickets you're gonna make you're
both gonna make more money than God to
set up your family
get it it's a sport that's where
fighting you know we want to say it's a
sport but then it is a [__] cage
fight
all right was it case fire is a sport
because a sport Tom Brady didn't have a
problem playing against his brother the
Kelsey Brothers didn't have a problem
beating each other it is what it is it's
a sport so I think we got to look at
this like a sport especially marab is a
business standpoint and you gotta you
gotta be here's the thing nobody's
offering the fight so you coming out uh
right after you win I would never fight
Al Jermaine but [__] dude you just
[__] yourself wait to even get the
offer because right now we're trying to
figure out there's a lot of hype around
them but him squashing that kind of
takes the win out of our sales wait till
you get the official offer to make a
comment on it nobody's even talking
about that right now aljo has to fight
[__] sahudo do you know in the UFC I
would assume
for murabi you know if he doesn't want
to fight aljo this is also assuming that
aljo beat sahuda which is a big if but
marab so who knows the fight
loves him Rob take sahuto down as many
times he took Peter yawn down that's
where we're going to find out what kind
of wrestling he has you ain't taking his
hoodo down like that so that's an
interesting fight his gas Tank's [__]
stupid stupid testing baby crazy yeah
this is crazy baby crazy gas day I had
to know where your head's going chin I
refuse to entertain it uh but perhaps
gas tank is [__] on the next level
um so you know from Rob you got Al Jones
can be busy with so who knows that's not
happening the UFC ain't gonna give you
sugar Shawn O'Malley who's ranked number
one here we ranked number two tell you
that right now they ain't giving you
sugar Shawn that's not a great matchup
for sugar so they didn't have sugar
fight Peter Johnson a good fight [__]
[__] that's not happening so I would
assume he gets the winner
out of um he would get the winner out of
Cheeto and Corey sandahagan
you know until they figure out what
happens to Alger sahuna but
um you know Cheeto marab's fun Cheetos
take down defense no punk and he hits
like a [__] back truck Corey Sam
Hagen pretty filthy on the ground it's
you know vicious submission so there's a
lot of fun fights out from Rob if I was
his team I'm like don't even comment on
alja right now you're taking the wind
out of your hype Sail you there's no
reason to do it dude just chill no one's
even offering you the [__] fight he
has this huge yes to fight Henry zahudo
one of the best ever do it first ballot
Hall of Famer let's get through that and
you're talking about you're already
talking about not fighting him what the
[__] are you doing it just took the the
hype sails away then we're like okay
that's not fun it's fun for us as
analysts and entertainers and fans to
talk about them find each other in their
clothes and you know that sells tickets
took that away yeah absolutely not to
think of this is how much you're gonna
make mom he's a holy [__] and dude think
about for so for aljo
you know if you were the big fighter
right he has to beat sahudo so let's say
he does beat sahuto which is a tough
[__] test man let's say he beat
sahuto his next money fight
I don't think is marab it'd be Sugar
Sugar Sean's right there so sugar would
get a title shot so marab you're looking
at
you're not even talking about sniffing a
title shot till early next year
but you've already squashed it
so he'd have to get through and this is
aljo he'd have to get through sahudo
sugar Shawn and then marapsing it there
that means Rob's probably have to fight
two more times
you know
but you already took the [__] window
from our [__] hype train sales dude
never fight him not never God damn
nobody even offered it
even like uh kind of like insinuated
that he was set in the Octagon after the
the post fight speech he was like me and
Alger know who the real Champion is
the champion is and he's a real Champion
so I feel like that kind of made it feel
like the fans are like maybe during
training that Alger does beat him or
something yeah maybe I don't know yeah
maybe that's what makes the fight fun
though exactly no so just remember
Gilbert Burns you speak the [__]
everybody I know in the sport told me
that Gilbert puts it on him and trade
him he over at this I went we're talking
about practice Yeah I only do real time
[__] yeah you know so from Rob that's a
fun story then they start talking [__]
about each other think about when when
TJ is fighting the team alpha male guys
you know
this is just fans love that stuff but
you killed it already yeah but now if
the UFC if it gets that point which a
lot has to happen for him to get to that
point A lot has to happen but boy is he
fun to watch that [__] is bad
that [__] is mad non-stop dude the
machine is [__] right I don't know if
the machine does them Justice dude we
gotta come up with another goddamn name
outside the machine
machines run out of gas but he doesn't
run out of gas he doesn't need gas [__]
your gas yeah yeah Tesla
well they run out of energy too yeah
he's like above all those things he's
the son he has a son he's the son Rob
the son
yeah
that was crazy to watch though he was
amazing
oh dude and I I saw all the fights that
had to go on stage in uh Oklahoma right
when they were walking out like oh
[__] I'm on set you know I'm on stage
for 60 minutes I'm like I'm definitely
not seeing this so I told our boy Tom
like hey give me play by plane
everything was like dominating
dominating dominating dominating like
holy [__]
yeah him just me like I would never
fight Alex you [__] up you [__]
yourself dude at least play that game
for us for a little bit yeah I don't
think he thinks about that stuff no
that's what makes him great yeah
there was another fight over the weekend
I know it's one of the greatest
lightweights on the planet is gone
Benson Henderson retired
I mean they just gave him a horrible
match up a new spin Champion yeah he's
been some [__] complete nightmare for
him
um how about your boy Michael Venom page
yeah that was weird the way it ended
what an awful injury I mean literally
just like Kink writing the [__] just
they said it ripped his Patel tendon I
popped it on the kneecap I mean you were
just dead and he's like oh my god what
the [__] are you doing dude it was
insane monkey van page a fun one he
needed that win too after that Mike
pairing loss
um so you know for Ben Henderson one of
the greatest ever do it I've told the
story multiple times but it seems
morphing now than ever first time I ever
decided to get into mixed martial arts I
signed up at uh John Crouch's Jiu Jitsu
at the time they're in Denver Colorado
now it's referred to as the lab in
Arizona but at the time John Crouch out
of an office building had the third
story and he ran a Jitsu gym there and
uh I just Google I Googled I just looked
up on the Internet like just do gyms in
the area I was working at a supplement
company at the time and it was like less
than two miles away so I'm like all
right that works for my jiu jitsu so I
uh you know type in the computer tells
me go there don't you know I don't know
anybody's just John Crouch black belt
I'm like all right this guy if he's
black belt knows what the [__] he's
doing so I get there you know I'm early
I'm probably 45 minutes early
and I'm rushing in with my stuff and I'm
holding the door open and uh either I'm
holding the door Ben Henderson's on the
door I think I'm holding the door open
for Ben and I go what's up dude he goes
what's up and uh and he goes what are
you doing I said ah man you know uh time
for jiu jitsu hopefully get to the UFC
man I mean what are you doing here and
he goes uh same same trying to get to
the UFC that was Ben Henderson we both
end up getting the UFC great [__]
dude and then he used to wrestle with my
head coach Lester bowling uh they're on
the same wrestling team in college so
I've known Ben for years one of the nice
guys in the sport ever such a [__]
monster you know had a just a story
career uh he's one of those guys who did
it without
you know without the WWE promos he did
the right way I think you know just a
classy classy example of a human being
and one of the greatest ever do it has a
great family wife's a badass uh you know
runs the gym out of there now him and
John Crouch no drama ever Ben Henderson
fought with a toothpick in his [__]
mouth yeah he's just a great [__]
dude handsome bastard you know just a
good good person man so
um good for him for going out you know
when he's going out man yeah half Korean
too which is right yeah yeah black and
cream such a nice kid man yeah so here's
just a clip a real quick clip of him at
the post fight press conference uh
getting emotional you ever seen what he
did in eight years
what do you mean beat the [__] out of
the ideas if you if you want to see how
good Ben harsh is then you obviously
Nate Diaz is a damn good fighter watch
him what he does his ideas if you if
y'all must have forgot how good [__]
Ben Henderson was and how flexible he is
it's not super flexible yes
big ass thugs yeah I'll play this clip
real quick
love you
yeah it has to be emotional man
get home to those babies Ben you ever
seen these kiddos mixed babies Jesus
Christ he's saying like his now his he's
gonna just help his wife out because she
started her in her MMA career and he's
going to take care of the kids and Let
Her Shine yeah yeah such a good guy man
yeah one of the good ones
um during that UFC fight there was
something kind of weird that happened so
uh Grant Davey so Rafael sensile he
retired as well yes right another great
another great yeah and then he's never a
champ man yeah or sorry Davey Grant so
David Grant who was also a fan favorite
he's awesome uh but he did grab the the
cage multiple times and then um I think
Keith Peterson was a referee and he
warned Warren a few times but then
finally took a point away No Nonsense my
ass
so but then the thing is he took a point
away but then he didn't reposition them
in the same spot because
let me just show you this which we I
don't think we can put on her but I'll
just show Brennan just so he has an idea
so this is where it happens right
so since I was on the bottom right now
but then right now he's on top right
yeah he looks like he's transitioning
yeah exactly so that's a pretty good
spot right the cage grabs a little weird
too because he's on top and it's not
like he was preventing a takedown it's a
weird time to take away a point so he
did take away a point and then he also
on the feet and then even since I was
like the whole time like what I'm about
to take his [__] back I'm also a
black belt and Brazilian Jiu Jitsu no
that's another really important Point
yeah so after that freaking he got us
David Grant did a spinning you know
attack and then freaking did a reverse
triangle or what do you call it inverted
trying inverter whatever he was like on
the other side to do the triangle and
then you know choked him out yeah and
won real shitty deal so this is the
sunsauce coach who's really cool Eric
nixik yeah Nick Sig's a badass yeah
first and foremost congrats to David
Graham to find a way to get it finished
with seconds left for a comeback Victory
um in questionable restarting position I
was told that Hatfield wasn't on top so
it was decided to take the point and
start from neutral I know
I disagree with that assessment because
when you watch it through
I feel complete the takedown despite the
fence grab at the very least it would
have made more sense to allow them to
restart from over under a single leg
position I think you should start with
him uh like with his arm wrapped up
yeah he's about to take his [__] back
as a black belt at the very least it
would have made more sense to allow them
to restart from over under single leg
position but certainly from a similar
position that represent the position
before the restart Keith Peterson is a
marvelous MMA referee I've always felt
good knowing he's in charge of one of
our fights although I may disagree with
the call I don't understand like Keith
did his job to the best of his abilities
to the rules given I can do be to be
happy to see Keith as a referee in the
future what an awesome statement let him
know how he feels but being like man
that was [__] up but also a great ref
so it's all good
that's where to restart him on the feed
after that very strange
so yeah if you were in that position you
would want to be and the other guy did
the foul not you yeah very strange
because why would the other guy is the
foul grantee God Point deducted but the
other guy does the foul and then they
put him in a Advantage yeah position
yeah otherwise then I just like oh
they're gonna do that I'm in trouble I'm
doing something illegal they're just
gonna restart the neutral position yeah
that can't be the rule set there's no
way
yeah I don't know what the actual rules
are yeah
um nobody does yeah
in different places too is always
different so this one was going
people have heard about this a lot so
Jake Paul the The Narrative I guess the
thing that's happening is that Jake Paul
ran away from Floyd Mayweather I would
too exactly so what happened was he went
he went to some like basketball game on
a Wednesday and then he was suddenly
suddenly approached by Floyd
Mayweather's team a bunch of dudes
apparently it was like I don't know 50.
he said 50 but not 50 is a big I know
there's a lot of people though yeah even
if even if it's eight it's a lot do yeah
you know what even if it's five
I'm lacing up these [__] off-white
trainers and running my ass out of there
five [__] I'm not designed to fight
five dudes and that's what aljamin
Sterling said too he's like there's five
people I'm out of there see ya no I
don't need them problems
um also Floyd why are you beat him up
you're still the Hat Thing
yeah he's Floyd you're 50. the Hat Thing
still clearly is just doing that for
publicity also you guys beat him up then
remember you got [__] up he had like a
black eye yeah
and this was a jake Paul's response so
I'm leaving the Miami Heat game and
Floyd Mayweather and 50 dudes pull up
out front of nowhere print out 50 but
let's say that is a lot yeah out of some
side alley waiting for me outside the
stadium they're like what's up what's
all the talk now I'm like well where's
Floyd why are you guys fighting this
fight I thought he's a real fighter 50
dudes literally starts around me to try
and jump me
um out that [__] Floyd you want to run
it one-on-one no problem but I'm not
dumb I'm tough I don't need to prove my
toughness but I'm not [__] dumb I'm
not gonna sit here and try to fight 50
dudes 50 dudes dipped out of that [__]
so funny it's so true though he he's
he's right he's a tough guy we know this
already yeah he's been in there he
fights yeah he don't need to prove his
toughness but is anybody sticking up for
Floyd or is anybody like how are you not
gonna fight 50 guys no well I didn't see
it I'm with Jay God run yeah and so then
he also tweeted that he wanted to fight
him one-on-one Floyd which is you know
yeah might as well might as well make
money doing it and uh our boy Ryan
Garcia had a take on it as well I'll
just play for you real quick
Jake Paul has a chance
you know what man I gotta say you know
Floyd's getting up there in age you know
but maybe he's he'll probably still beat
up Jake but guess what Jake won't get
knocked out I'll probably 100 that he
couldn't knock out Logan and you know he
shouldn't be running up on a guy with 50
dudes that ain't right you look at the
truth of that you know it is what it is
yeah but again I ain't worried about
that I'm worried about knocking out
Brian looks so overpressed right now
everybody's gonna knock him out he's
gonna put him to sleep you know he looks
like Hugh Grant at the Oscars you see
that yeah he's not having it
yeah I mean I'm with Ryan I don't think
Floyd would beat him but would knock him
out not a chance and here's a real quick
one with chill I mean in a nutshell
she'll just said like that should be a
crime the guy filming it said like hey
we should probably you know get this guy
whatever and he filmed it and then
published it right so that's on Floyd's
team he's like that guy's such an idiot
for even yeah you do that yeah
which I agree with you
and this is funny this is how Jake Paul
reacted to it he posted this
right here
he goes my pure speed athleticism and 99
awareness rating helped me avoid getting
jumped so I can still flick up this fit
this morning and then he has like a cool
outfit on but yeah pretty little Audi
I'm sure that's a super expensive watch
yeah I don't like those watches same but
I'm sure it's so expensive
yeah so that's the end of the game
that's that's before he was
no this is a good job
that's how that's how he responded which
is fine that's funny yeah yeah and then
this is a little bit of a later post but
this is what he did after he lost
his boxing match he was professional
boxer and then he's with FedEx boxes and
he's actually boxing the boxes yeah
he has a good sense of humor yeah
good for him it's all a game to those
boys dude he's killing the game crushes
yeah destroying the game uh so this is I
don't know how legit this is but Ali
Abdel Aziz did a tweet saying that the
the last pay-per-view Jones versus
Cereal gone 285 uh is almost at one
million and I do know he's connected to
them pretty well so he might yeah he's
definitely the closest manager to Dana
um
I believe it I don't believe a lot of
this [__] but I believe it has to be
close a the just the demand for Jon
Jones come back it's heavyweight for
World title then also that I think I saw
it was like the most trending most
talked about fight UFC fight and social
media I think even it beat out Eddie
Alvarez and uh Conor McGregor and Conor
Nate online which usually that hype
equals pay-per-view Buys so I would
imagine and here's the thing there's
this weird narrative that John didn't
sell pay-per-views no no John doesn't
sell pay-per-views compared to you know
maybe a Connor or Brock Lesnar but
outside that he's a big earner man yeah
and I think that's the UFC said that
remember when John pulled out of the
trail fight Dana spun this narrative why
dimitroen product I've never understood
it but you know there's this narrative
where John just people aren't tuning in
to watch him I you look at all his major
pay-per-views they sold really well
especially for today's standards now
back then when the pay-per-view model
was when it was yeah he's not a Brock
Lesnar but Brock Lesnar wasn't as active
as uh John John Sells pay-per-views
people want to watch John fight and to
that point even though Dana said that
stuff he actually canceled that entire
card because John couldn't make it and
then yeah yeah if he's not a big draw
then White Castle yeah exactly
um so with Ollie on this I bet it does
well yeah I feel like it's gonna be
around a million for sure
um this is Dana White saying that um
Rumble I love the platform yeah I love
dance Double Adele like he's just that
Matrix yes that Matrix meme with him
Dodge and all of it he's like no we want
to go to rumble no we didn't want to be
on TBS the people are loving on Tick
Tock it's just all this you know there's
some stuff to this that I'll tell you
about all right okay yeah so this is
what he's saying like
so the numbers are kind of tricky right
so so it says Dana White's powershop
league is uh held its inaugural season
finale which has just ended now
and while I wasn't on pay-per-view
originally as originally attended it
pulled in a robust 2.1 million viewers
on YouTube now I'll say this to defend
Dana before before you're gonna give me
a thing I will say this is
um the fan base who are gonna tune in to
to
you know TV or the I should say that's a
fan base that's going to tune into two
grown men slapping each other for
entertainment or the fan base who's
gonna tune into
you know even a Tim Dylan uh interview
on Alex Jones isn't the same fan base
who's tuned in to CBS on Wednesday night
so that's not even their demo not even
close there's bigger money there with
the ad sales on TV because TV pays more
but as far as getting out to eyeballs
that fan base is on YouTube that fan
base is on social media so Dave is right
when it comes to that but TV the the the
demo of TV isn't that fan base he of
course he's bigger online of course it's
bigger on YouTube of course yeah
uh so yeah so in this article you know
it showed like 2.1 million viewers which
is pretty crazy but apparently I don't
know how they do this but it went live
on Friday but the event was like I guess
on Saturday so they started
calculating since Friday like anyone
that wondered it was interested in that
thing would count as a view or whatever
so uh the actual TV views were 220 000
viewers for the finale but it says the
you know robust 2.1 million viewers for
the whole thing but you know but again
the the demo is not on TV I I think they
made a mistake thinking that this should
even be on TV
no that's why that's why you say he has
like a deal with Rumble yeah that's
that's but he's got completely extreme
the original plan was to have this big
success like you see on TV even that
took years for people to sign on to
powerslap the TV demo the older demo
even you know I'll be 40 on Saturday I'm
not into it's too much for me yeah now
imagine my parents they're not [__]
into it those that's your TV demo so I
think they [__] up off the bat put it
on TV of course it was gonna eat [__] on
there but on YouTube clips on social
media world star it's gonna crush on
there and if they can figure out that
business model yeah it's gonna be
success there's a lane for it it's just
not on TV I'd rather watch The Last of
Us
I'd rather watch March Madness that's TV
I'm not watching March Madness on
YouTube I'm not watching March Madness
on Tick Tock you know this is a young
Tick Tock like that's their fan base
like they're that's why you'll see like
the milk boys tweeting out that's that's
this fan base that's what he did it's
complete opposite of the UFC notice the
UFC fan base hates it when they post
about it it's just all hate
it's just all hates yeah it it's it's
the same as like Jake Paul's fan base
isn't into uh Leon Edwards versus Usman
this weekend they're not okay but that's
a fan base so quit trying to make the
UFC fan base who's this tried and true
fan base like powerslap man just go down
your other lane the problem is you mixed
them so when you mix them you're
assuming that this fan base likes that
[__] they hate it listen to them
and that's not an L for Dana you need
younger fans yeah do that that's why
he's with the milk boys that's why you
know they flew out all these influencers
and all the YouTubers to the powerslide
fat Fight League and like you saw Will
Compton like this is the greatest thing
I've ever been to but if you will
and I love busting with the boys Taylor
and will and I get it man I get it
here's my thing I don't hate people
think just because I have no issue with
the data I think people think because
Dave is involved I hate power I don't
hate Powers I believe but it's on I
watch I'm like this is insane this is
allowed in 2023. now if they invite me I
go I'd go for the [__] show but like hey
can you pose how cool it is I'm like I
don't know about that I can light some
of the guys up for you if you want and
make fun of them online you know and I
actually respect what they're doing it's
nuts it's nuts the balls they have to
get slapped in the face it's just it my
problem is is you're blowing the lines
because you're forcing me to consume
something that I didn't sign up for yes
that's my problem forcing me when I
follow the UFC or Dana White I'm only
following you because I want to see Leon
Edwards who's 20 and 4 versus uzman
who's 20 and two I want that high level
[__] I don't want this [__] that'd
be like sign up for you know some legit
ABC news station and you're giving
Comedy Central Comedy [__] like that's
not what I'm here for exactly and like
oh you guys hate this like I never asked
you why are you doing this to me yeah I
didn't pay for this
so that's where Dana [__] up he
thought it was a similar fan base it's
completely opposite and he's getting the
hate from the people because he's
forcing on him but if you just focus on
that younger fanbase the Logan Paul the
Jake Paul the milk boys that's who's
into this [__] God bless you man you
make a [__] ton they make all the money
over there just do that quit trying to
[__] with everybody over here you know
yeah I mean he's just going about the
wrong way you know why because he's 60.
that's why that's 60. he's damn near 60.
he's close to Rogan's age 56 57 or
whatever [__] is Rogan's 55 at 55 you're
not gonna understand that you think oh
if this is entertaining they like UFC
they're gonna like this no [__]
no I hate this I do yeah and I that all
I the only Sports I watch is MMA I don't
watch any other sports no I watch
everything I watch everything but here's
what let me find it don't exactly when I
when I want to see uh old school
throwback clip of Usman Leon Edwards the
first fight someone when I'm looking at
two of the highest level caliber
fighters of all time to do it and then I
watch some guy in a [__] with tits
slapping each other I that's not what I
asked for dude yeah that's why I'm
following no you're catfishing me yeah
you catfished me I'm expecting Double
D's you set this flat chested girl over
and I and then you're upset I don't want
it
yeah because I like Double D's you keep
sending a flat chest to check
yeah you can't fish the audience things
like good I can't believe they don't
like it yeah [__] we nobody asked for
this we didn't nobody in the history
there she was like you know what I think
we should get guys together and slap
each other never and knock them out
never never we didn't ask for it then
you're mad because we're like hey man
can you not do it over here you know
yeah and I scroll past so fast because I
don't want them to have this here's a
lane for that it's a massive very very
cash filled Lane
just focus on that quit trying to push
on us and we'll calm down how much they
paid but if you tweet one more time
about the this is in Slade hey Dana can
I try some of your tacos and he's all
delicious best I've ever had I'm like
you [__] sell out dude you sell out
bro he's done but I get it oh where's
one of my favorite people it's just
funny to watch and I give him a chip he
knows it yeah he knows it he's one he
did the the [__] Friday for yeah I
create that name it's whatever no no I'm
saying uh Danny White has [__] Friday
no I know he's going to try the taco
they did it yeah yeah they did it
I I get those boys are on their rise
right now they're on the wave and that's
part of the wave and I'm completely
co-signed I'm on board I do the exact
same thing I think it's entertaining
it's funny I have no issues with it like
that I just it's funny give them [__]
because he's like this power and you
know they're talking about one guy who
played in the pro ball played in the
[__] you know for the Titans you know
Taylor is one of the best football
tackles of all time they have Will
Compton who's a 10-year vet in the NFL
for them like this is completely insane
these athletes are really put on the
line I'm like hey calmed down a tad will
just a tad like if you I get selling out
just a tad just take it down a notch for
me dude I love seeing it though I love
it man yeah it's entertaining I'll give
Dana that hands down he knows what's
entertaining
it isn't for a small but I don't want on
my feed though I just don't want on my
feed yeah you know why because you
didn't ask for it yeah but I'm not gonna
unsubscribe I don't want giant black
dicks on my feet if you start doing it
and be like oh you guys just don't like
it because I'm involved it's like no no
wait what no no has nothing to do that I
just don't like big giant black dicks in
my face
well I'd prefer to see giant black did
them two men slapping each other
and again there's a lane for that and
they make a lot of money yeah
tailored towards them is the point of
this not it's not about big black [__]
oh my goodness all right um these kids
don't watch TV no [__] that's my point
to this entire rant
so there is a little bit of controversy
on this this is from bjpen.com
uh someone found out that you know how
like they put like Twitter posts on
screen like someone said something you
don't have theovan said stuff about you
have something there's another one will
deal shitty fight night oh my God Dana
the the fight gods have blessed this man
gotta take my money hey can I donate
some more money this fight's way too
entertaining these guys will be banging
but at least those tweets are real I see
them all
hey guys tone it down a notch I know so
okay so this is from a Twitter username
Matthew Wells he posted so he did a
screenshot of this by the way this is
from BJ penn.com I don't know how legit
this is but the screenshot says as you
can see here
Alex Alex underscore or Alexis
underscore villums he says wow that slap
delivered by Rivera was crazy hey real
quick I'll tell you that's fake people
watch top Fight League aren't talking
like that so that's Wow fight delivered
and then this guy looked at his page and
he never tweeted it right so he looked
at his actual handle he never tweeted it
and then there's another one from
CJ whatever Goodell also no one just
watches laugh lightly going that's a bad
man I know like well Dorian Perez is a
bad man hashtag powerslap and then so
this guy once again looked at his
Twitter and didn't see anything of it
and these guys have like eight followers
25 followers so even that's kind of like
you know whatever weird you know I get
it so they're they're saying there's a
potential thing where the UFC might be
or the power slap League whatever it
might be falsifying these oh don't see I
don't know why you do it you're on
covering them wrong and you look under
that rock I can go deep on yeah UFC
you know creating false narratives from
social media with this stuff and going
after and getting people a lot of hate
from from and started with the
underground forms and stuff like that
yeah and they'll send you know people
towards you and pay people to send hate
your way
don't get me started I'm not gonna get
started so it is
what you're trying to do this is so and
then so they he searched I guess you
could search on Twitter and then
apparently you know that all the quotes
that we saw they never existed on
Twitter here's the thing yeah well yeah
if you got to put up fake tweets it's
not going great but the thing is too is
in this day and age kids are so good at
social media so they're so good I'm a
dinosaur kids are so good at it if
you're gonna put this stuff out trust me
it's gonna get found out but here's the
thing
no one gives a [__] you're sitting on
your [__] okay
yeah you got us okay prove it no we know
man this doesn't exist okay moving on
yeah
it's true yeah of course they do that if
they can get away with it they're gonna
keep doing it
oh you think it's their first time no I
mean still there don't get me started
they're very smart at this which is
they're great yeah Shady yeah yep uh
just a quick one Henry pseudo who's
gonna it's a apparently oh yeah Dana
White actually said it's official now
Henry sujudo versus right yep so uh
Henry sudo says if algerman somehow
backs out for whatever reason injury he
wants some Rob
which I think would be dope too yeah let
me be trained together that makes sense
you mentioned how much that would be a
badass fight [__] yeah I mean I'll train
so who is the amazing fight Rob amazing
fight sign me up for any of them
and this is Dana White talking about
uh Francis zangano on TMZ basically
saying that did this come out before or
after I said this
this has to be after because I said the
exact same thing
you know what it's not like this it's
not like we're Reinventing the wheel
Hood this isn't like an original thought
I mean I didn't get it from Dana Dana
yet for me 100 John beats Francis just
as easy to beat Cyril gone just as easy
none of these boys can grapple now the
only outliers Francis hit so [__]
hard if he were to get clip coming in
it's game over there's that Hail Mary
for him outside that John mops the floor
with Francis unfortunately
so Dana says it's on TMZ sports I'm not
interested Francis wants to come back he
says that he's not interested
yeah we've all known he says stuff that
he lets people back you know said women
would never fight you'll see look at how
we're doing but we're doing like I'm a
chick but also
um if there's there's a lot of rumbles
of and I know for a fact Francis and
Deontay Wilder are about to sign a deal
and get announced pretty soon here so uh
if Francis in some weird alternate
reality that we're living in is knocked
out Deontay Wilder you don't think Dana
would have him back for the biggest
heavyweight fight of all time Francis
Jon Jones
come on now that's predicated on Francis
winning because Francis gets Molly by
Wilder which odds are but if he didn't
if he gets Molly wopped that yeah it's
never happened but if he beats him yeah
right they don't sign him the next
[__] day
try to make the fight two years ago he
didn't want the fight know what I mean
he didn't want the fight and he left
here without even having another deal in
place not true and I know how boxing
world is it's crazy but Francis didn't
want to fight Jon nobody too
disappointed white says France almost
certainly would have been easy work for
the goat let me tell you what I think a
lot of other people feel this way I
think that's exactly the way the fight
would have gone if igana would it was in
there too yeah I agree odds are he's
right
and then ngano said something like uh I
don't care what Dana White says and he
wanted that fight and whatever just
didn't work out
yeah I believe I don't think France is
scared of John I think it's one of those
I just think you want to make more money
and plus he had all his things he wanted
to do outside of the Octagon so now on
firing the kid I don't think I this was
on uh Monday's episode Wednesday's
episode one of those yeah I said Brock
was John everyone's thing you got to
remember Brock and John that's the fight
and I think John has one or two fights
left I think it's deep a maybe one more
and if it's Brock could do it but
outside that he's probably done
so what Dana White says here is like he
doesn't think it's gonna happen but the
way he words it I just looked into it so
this is how what this is what he said
Brock and I have a great relationship
and we always have
um but I don't think Brock wants to find
any more Brock's made a lot of money
came to the UCM won the heavyweight
title he's got nothing left to prove I
don't think he'd want to do it I think
that's just Danny White's saying like I
don't think yeah he's he's good he
wouldn't want no partner Jones
then Brock trying to like say what
you know yeah all right so this is it's
not official news wherever but Kevin Lee
you know he just recently got back with
the UFC and he hinted at a rematch with
because he lost I guess the first time
against uh Tony Ferguson yeah
and he put this in his uh Instagram
story and he put it's a half face of
Tony Ferguson half face of him and he
goes time history I love Kevin Lee I
think it's a great matchup too
um
this would be super quick this is in
2020s before cereal gone fought Jon
Jones uh khabib asked siragon after
watching the igana fights come to
dagasan come here for like a year and a
half two years and then learn wrestling
because you know you have no wrestling
yeah he's like you're from France
there's nothing there or whatever yeah
so yeah that was like an offer back then
um let's go oh your boy yeah I love this
he's coming back yeah he's gonna fight
Charles Jordan that's my guy and I
looked at their records because I forgot
when Crone fought but it was in October
2019. I don't know why they tossed some
cups wants him back again
yeah horrible fight but but Charles
Jordan he fought September 2022 and then
he left he's like two losses in a row
um this also Alexander music versus
Tyson Fury
so they agree they agree to this
Heavyweight Championship match and I
think the thing that was in between it
was the angana thing it was these guys
didn't fight but now they're apparently
gonna fight and that's why Francis is
focusing on Wilder yeah yeah uh that's
it man all right kids that was a fun one
uh this Saturday 2 p.m Pacific time got
Leon Edwards Kamara Usman Justin gaichi
faziv it is going down also my boy Jack
Shore is back at it featherweight bigger
batter Jackie Shore come get you some
Leon Edwards Camaro Smith going down for
the main event fight Japan Rogan is not
happening uh Jamie has some golf thing
he has to do and my family's doing some
stuff for my b day so it just did not
work out so rescheduling for the next
fight companion in Austin Texas with Joe
Rogan we might do a fight command here
at thick boy we're trying to get the
team together now keep you guys posted
but enjoy the fights either way I'll
post on social media announce Wednesday
I'm finding the kid if we are having a
companion on uh Saturday so we'll see
try and get the sent out the bad signal
we'll see but uh enjoy the fight 202 86
and next up for me spoken is next week
next Thursday Friday Saturday spoken see
you there one of my favorite I'm sorry
it's Tacoma Tacoma is next week that's
Thursday Friday Saturday March 23rd
through 25th Tacoma Washington Tacoma
comedy club right outside Seattle come
get you some I'll be uh rocking my Sean
Kemp uh Jersey because it's right
outside Seattle so get some thickboy.com
or fataz.com that's it kids love you
enjoy the fights be safe until next time